wer seinem klinker hat alles verloren
auch in dieser flut ist noch dazu schwer
krank und schafft es trotzdem allen
anderen menschen zu helfen und das ist
für uns absolut bewundernswert
das ist balsam klinker wie so viele hat
sie alles verloren
die flut kam und raubte ihre fans ihr
hab und gut ihre komplette existenz
jetzt steht die an brustkrebs erkrankte
börsen vor dem nichts
wir treffen sie in altena auf dem
parkplatz eines hotels
wir haben überall drei tage war es gar
nicht geschlafen
ich bin ja selber kennt krank und ich
denn die alte dame nicht wie war meine
nachbarin gewesen mich alleine lassen
und gedanken man ruft an überall der
geht gar nicht man leitet immer weiter
weiter weiter und ich habe alles und man
haus alles komplett gestört ich kann
nichts mehr retten gar nicht sehen ja
wie ich aussehe
ich habe gar nichts
ich habe immer gern im schatten
glanzkinder ich habe den namen schwester
gelassen aber wer auch nur ein zimmer
wohnung
trotz ihres elends den gesamt nicht an
sich ihre schwerbehinderte nachbarin
ingrid ist bei ihr
wir haben ja da unten kein wasser kein
strom gar nichts und bei meiner
behinderung sie hilft mir ja immer und
ewig besser wenn wir da raus gehen
nach einer stundenlangen odyssee hat
börse für die beiden nun endlich einen
schlafplatz gefunden
ein warmes bett ein kleines bisschen
menschlichkeit ohne die flut heldin
börse wäre ingrid auf sich alleine
gestellt
doch auch wenn die beiden für eine nacht
eine unterkunft haben wie es morgen
aussieht wo sie morgens schlafen ist
ungewiss doch eines ist sicher börse ist
die helden des tages
sie hat gezeigt dass menschlichkeit und
nächstenliebe stärker sind als jede flut
berührend unsere heldin die sich um
andere um ingrid ihre nachbarin kümmert
bei seinem klinker ist uns jetzt auch
zugeschaltet jetzt inmitten in dieser
katastrophe in der sie auch noch anderen
menschen hilft ihrer nachbarin ingrid
wie geht es ihnen wie ist die situation
derzeit bei ihnen gerade wissen sie
vielleicht schon wann sie wieder in ihr
haus zurückkehren können
mir fehlen die worte und ich hab zeit
statt katastrophe über ganz geschlafen
ich konnte überhaupt gar nicht schlafen
wann die bilder die chance gesehen habe
den laufen immer noch in meinem kopf
drehen sich immer weiter ich weiß es
nicht
das ist das einzige worte ich hab' ich
weiß überhaupt gar nicht was keine
ahnung und trotzdem schaffen sie es für
andere menschen da zu sein
woher nehmen sie diese kraft wir alle
können uns das überhaupt nicht nicht mal
ansatzweise vorstellen was was ihnen
passiert ist wie es ihnen gehen muss und
umso bewundernswerter ist es dass sie
das hier so durchhalten und dass sie so
zusammenhalten wie schaffen sie das
ja das ist ja das kommt von innen dann
das macht man einfach nur einfach so
willmann und wenn andere menschen sieht
helfer braucht man gibt alles ich bin
ich setze gerade habe ich hier mit den
kollegen gesprochen dass ich ja jetzt
meinen kreis weil ich hab ja auch fast
immer in zwei tage fast 24 kilometer
über die weinberge gelaufen war
einmal bin ich runter von meinem mann ex
tool und danach in reichertshofen und
dann weiter über die beiden berger wo
ich in mein handy angeschaltet habe und
habe ich hier die die helfer von ingrid
gehört dann bin ich weiter wieder über
die weinwelt auch untergegangen und ich
hab dir auch rausgeholt
es sind bilder die sie gar nicht mehr
loswerden wir merken wie berührt sie
sind es berührt uns auch sehr dass sie
sich da so sehr einsetzen
wir erzählen wie sie über die weinberge
rennen um ingrid so holen sie haben
ihren sohn noch zu ihrer schwester in
sicherheit gebracht wie geht es ihnen
jetzt wo sind sie gerade haben sie
jemanden der sich auch um sie kümmert
mit dem sie das all das schreckliche
erlebte auch irgendwie an arbeiten
können wir sind jetzt gerade wir haben
wo das passiert ist nach kollegen
gefunden da im hotel und die haben uns
um so in einer androhte geschickt wir
danken den mal erst mal für einen tag
für heute und heute müssen wir noch mal
rausgehen und ja wir wissen auch jetzt
nichts mehr wo mir fehlen wird ist die
worte ich weiß es nicht
frau klinker wir wünschen ihnen alles
erdenklich gute das so schnell wie
möglich hilfe kommt dass sie so schnell
wie möglich wieder in ein normales
einigermaßen normales leben kommen ich
glaube wir können gar nicht genug
betonen wie sehr wir in das wünschen
vielen vielen dank dass sie sich hier
die zeit genommen haben und somit uns
darüber gesprochen haben danke ihnen
alles gute ihnen von herzen
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren